here to explain more about why clowns
are upset is our friend butterscotch the
clown let's get a minier butterscotch
now you you want to say something to
people who are still thinking of
dressing up as creepy clowns for
Halloween is that right yes don't do it
that clown from it is a child murdering
monster and it makes real clowns look
bad when most of us are sweet and
harmless I don't know a single clown
who's committed a murder okay well
that's good to hear butterscotch it's a
good man yeah you know I take that back
I know one but just one murder clown
that's almost zeroed I think most of us
don't know any murderers butterscotch
but but that's okay let me ask you do
you have any plans for Halloween this
year too
I'm sorry what I know two clowns who've
murdered people
I'd forgotten anywho I love Halloween
and I can't wait to have kids over to my
place I've got it all decorated no
butterscotch I don't think that's gonna
work out very well for you but this year
thanks to the mean clown from it I'm
making sure kids know I one of the nice
clowns that is why I will be greeting
trick-or-treaters in this shirt okay no
butter now don't encourage him look
butterscotch kids are just gonna see
that and think that means you will
murder them that's what they're going to
think that is why I added this message
on the back that's creepy I'm sorry it's
it's what you're doing is creepy plus
you could forget those scary clown
costumes because I've got some great
silly costume ideas who wants to see
I don't want to see anything check it
out it's a headless horse clown and see
he's happy not scary you know I gotta
give it out butterscotch that's actually
kind of a cute costume don't worry about
carrying candy because this costume is
hands-free
[Applause]
guess how he's holding up the pumpkin
code I don't want to get I don't want to
guess he's just thinking about you okay
I like it I don't like it I don't like
it
here's an here's another cute one
another great costume idea it's a clown
get it it's a cow and clown tepee you
know I have to say that's a little
clever and it's sweet he's got little
Halloween cookies mm-hmm you can't have
cookies without milk
[Applause]
butterscotch please go right now
that's disgusting go okay but not before
I do my happy Halloween dance hit it
yeah kombucha
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
we got a great show tonight we got a
great show tonight from the hit look at
his face get it on that face
from the head
from the hit HBO series Curb Your
Enthusiasm author of the new book The
Book of Leon philosophy before JB Smoove
is I'm Sarah
Arthur and the new book I'm fine another
lies treating Whitney Cummings
P and Joakim booster
[Applause]
you